معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد مع ارتفاع خسائر الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان كان ضباط او جنود ومع
ارتفاع منسوب غضب عائلات المحتجزين لدى
المقاومه يرتفع صوت المطالبين والذين
يتحدثون عن وقف اطلاق النار اخرهم السفير
الاسرائيلي في واشنطن الى اي مدى يبدو هذا
الطرح موضوع بقوه على طاوله
الاسرائيليين
فعلا بدا يسجل زخما في الشارع الاسرائيلي
اخرهم بعد السفير الاسرائيلي في الولايات
المتحده رئيس الحكومه الاسبق ايهود براك
الذي ايضا ادلى بحديث للاذاعه الاسرائيليه
قال فيه انه يؤيد ابرام صفقه تبادل بيتم
بموجبها اعاده كافه المحتجزين في قطاع غزه
في مقابل الافراج عن عدد كبير من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين حتى لو كانوا من الاسرى
الثقال او من وصفهم بالملط خه اياديهم
الدماء هذا يدلل على ان الموضوع عاد لياخذ
زخمه تماما مثل ما تفاعل في الايام
الاخيره التي سبقت هدنه الاسبوع التي في
اطارها تم ابرام ست صفقات تبادل للاسرى
بين حركه حماس وبين اسرائيل هذه المره
ايضا الموضوع يتفاعل المعلومات المتسربه
عن دوائر القرار في اسرائيل مع عوده
المداولات بين الوسطاء و الم المتفاوضين
سواء كانوا القطريين والمصريين والولايات
المتحده واسرائيل ايضا فان الحديث يقول
بان اسرائيل تقدمت بمقترح بموجبه مستعده
لوقف اطلاق النار لاسبوعين باطار يتم
افراج عن نحو 40 من المحتجزين في قطاع غزه
على ان يكونوا من النساء والاطفال
والمتقدمين بالسن والمرضى من الاسرائيليين
في مقابل ان تفرج عن ثلاثه اضعف عا في هذا
العدد خلال هذه المده من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين وبينهم اسرى كما يسمونهم من
العيار الثقيل هكذا يصفهم الاسرائيليون
وهذا في محاوله لاغراء حركه حماس على
الموافقه لكن حماس تضع شرطا بانها مستعده
لوقف تام لاطلاق النار في مقابل ابرام
صفقه شامله الكل في مقابل الكل لكن الواضح
بان الموضوع فعلا يتفاعل لقاء نتنياهو
بذوي او بوفد عن ذوي المحتجزين في قطاع
غزه
والاسرى امس وايضا استمرار احتجاجاتهم هذه
تعززت في مؤخرا بعد ان كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد قتل ثلاثه من الرهائن
المحتجزين في الشجاعيه وقال ان ذلك كان عن
طريق الخطا وتبين انه كان هناك فشل ذريع
استخبارات اسرائيلي من انه من ان الاوامر
لم تصل الى الجنود في الميدان و وهذا قد
اثار ذوي المحتجزين الذين عادوا ليحذروا
من ان استمرار العمليه البريه الاسرائيليه
والقصف الجوي بهذه الضراوه من شانه ان
يقضي او يعرض ابنائهم الموجودين في قطاع
غزه لخطر الموت هؤلاء عادوا وواصلوا من
احتجاجاتهم في تل ابيب تحديدا في منطقه
مفرق اصبح يعرف بميدان المخطوفين وايضا في
منطقه مجمع قياده الا الاجهزه الامنيه
والجيش ووزاره الدفاع ورئاسه الوزراء حيث
يواصل تواصل الحكومه الاسرائيليه في
هيئاتها الثلاثه كمجلس وزاري هيئه عامه
وكمجتمع
مداولاتها الحثيثه لذلك يبدو ان المؤشرات
تتعزز يوما تلو الاخر ما اذا ستنضج صفقه
جديده هذه ستثبت الايام المقبله لكن واضح
بان الموضوع بدا يسجل زخما من المفاجات
ايضا التي صدم بها
الاسرائيليون بالاضافه لكل هذه الامور هو
ان ان يكتشفوا او تكتشف منظومتهم الامنيه
متاخره بان القائد الاعلى للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه
اي محمد ضيف ايه حي يرزق بكامل صحته ويسير
على قدميه وانه بصحه جيده جدا وفق ما
وصلهم قالوا من معلومات وعادت لتحاول ان
تقول بانه كان لديها مثل هذه المعلومات من
قبل لكن هذا الموضوع اثبت بنظري
اسرائيليين كثر بان هناك فشل استخباراتي
جديد لديهم بهذا الخصوص ضيف كان قد تعرض
سبع مرات لمحاولات اغتيال من قبل اسرائيل
اخرها كان في حرب عام
2014 عندما قصفوا منزلا تواجدت فيه عائلته
في الشيخ رضوان بغزه وقد استشهد عائلته
واعداد كبيره من اسرته بينما نجى هو وقيل
في حينه بانه اصيب بجراح خطيره جدا في
ساقيه ويديه وجسده وان وضعه الصحي صعب
الان تاتي هذه المعلومات
لتشكل صدمه جديده للاسرائيليين المعلومات
الاخرى التي يتحدثون عنها وانها تشكل حلقه
جديده في متواليه الفشل الاستخباري لدى
الاسرائيليين هي ان قواتهم تق قول بانها
وصلت الى منازل ومواقع تواجد فيها زعيم
حماس في غزه يحيى السنوار لكنه نجح
بالفرار منها قبل وصول قواتهم هذا بخصوص
خان يونس التي تشهد معارك ضاريه جدا ويقول
الجيش انه دفع بلواء اضافي للمعارك هناك
وانه دخل في معارك على محاور جديده لم
يسبق له ان دخل بمعارك فيها او خاضها في
الفتره الاخيره منذ ان استهدف اي خان يونس
التي يصفها بالمعقد الرئيسي والاساسي يضاف
الى هذه كله انه عاد ليعلن بانه قد تمكن
من احتلاله بسط احتلاله كاملا على مخيم
جباليا وانه اعتقل انه قتل نحو 1000 من
المقاومين واعتقل نحو 500 ومن بينهم نحو
70 ممن شاركوا في عمليه طوفان الاقصى في
السابع من اكتوبر واقتحموا منطقه غلاف غزه
لكن على ارض الميدان ما تزال القتال
متواصل حتى في اقصى شمال قطاع غزه وفي
مناطق مثل بيت لهيه وبيت حنون التي كان قد
بدا توغله البر بره المها في الس 26 والعش
من اكتوبر الماضي وهذا ما تقوله الان مثل
ما نشاهد مصادر عسكريه اسرائيليه قوات
الجيش تواجه مقاومه قويه وتخوض قتالا
ضاريا وقاسيا في كل محاور غزه اذا
المقاومه ما تزال قادره على خوض معارك
ضاريه محمد الضيف ما زال حي في غزه
ونتنياهو يتحدث ويطلب ت جيل جلسات محاكمته
لانشغاله با اداره الحرب على غزه ما الذي
يعنيه هذا الموقف من نتنياهو وكيف ينظر
اليه في الداخل
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو متهم اسرائيليا على
كافه المستويات بانه يحاول اولا دحرجه
المسؤوليه عن الفشل الامني والاستخباري
والعسكري في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي على
القيادات الامنيه والعسكريه ويريد التهرب
حتى الان لا يعلن عن مسؤوليته كما اعلن
كافه القاده الاسرائيليين ثانيا نتنياهو
يحاول استغلال الحرب لتاخير استمرار
محاكمته على ثلاث ملفات
فساد الى اجل غير مسمى على امل ان ينجوا
من ذلك بعد الحرب والامر الثالث بنظر
الاسرائيليين فان نتنياهو كل همه هو ان
يثبت توليفته اليمينيه المتطرفه فلتب
ليبقى على راس الحكومه حتى نهايه ولايتها
الى ما بعد نحو ثلاث سنوات واكثر لذلك في
نظر الاسرائيليين هو فاقد ل اهليه لمواصله
الحكم وهو فاقد ايضا للثقه من قبل الشارع
الاسرائيلي وهو ما تؤشر اليه اسبوعيا
استطلاعات الراي التي تبين اخرها بانه قد
فقد نحو اكثر من 50% من شعبيته سواء كزعيم
لرئيس الحكومه او كزعيم لحزب الليكود لذا
كل مطالب نتنياهو يرى الاسرائيليون ان
هدفها هدفها الاساسي هو محاوله التهرب
ومحاوله خدمه مصالحه وسياسته الشخصيه فقط
وانه لا لا يلتفت للمصلحه الوطنيه وللحرب
وانما يستغلها في محاوله للتهرب وابعاد
محاكمته قدر الامكان بذري انه منشغل في
الحرب تاجيل هذه المحاكمه شكرا جزيلا لك
وليد العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره من رم الله